combinaison intégrale de rigueur avec
gants et casque pour se glisser dans une
eau à 17 degrés la nage en eau vive un
sport de loisir mais aujourd'hui il
faudra réaliser le meilleur temps je
vais déjà essayer de pas rater porte ce
sera déjà pas mal
et puis après on verra passer surtout
pour le plaisir donc voilà et c'est
parti toutes les minutes en nageurs se
lance dans les rapides du bassin de
châteauneuf sur cher il faut passer
entre les piquets des portes vertes est
remonté à contre-courant pour passer
entre les piquets des portes rouges
pas facile avec tous ces remous les juge
vérifie que les passages sont bien
effectués et notent les éventuelles
erreurs on n'a pas le droit de toucher
les portes c'est le meilleur chrono qui
lie une porte touché ces deux secondes
de pénalité une porte manquée c'est 50
secondes de pénalité un parcours comme
ça va se faire en deux minutes pour les
meilleurs deux minutes 35
donc si vous rajoutez les pénalités ont
peu ça peut aller loin
les nageurs bataille avec les courants à
la seule force de leurs palmes et avec
pour seul appui un flotteur qui sert de
direction un slalom qui va très très
vite
à l'arrivée les concurrents sont épuisés
c'est dur j'avais plus trop de racheter
vadier c'est dur la de remonter la
dernière porte aux usa plus dur un appui
de plus de 20 plus de forcer et c'est la
fin ce championnat de france rassemble
les meilleurs nageurs en eaux vives
une soixantaine d'entre eux s'affrontent
dans cette descente tristan guillard
pratique ce sport depuis dix ans à
issoudun
il termine à bout de souffle mais
deuxième chrono parcours est très
technique très épuisant et donc
compliqué à choper la france très
compliqué et donc pour la poste- manche
des petits diarra un peu bête mais dans
l'ensemble très correct les trois
premiers devraient s'envoler pour les
championnats du monde au guatemala dans
cette nouvelle discipline les français
n'ont pas peur de se jeter à l'eau